facing kyle gibson gibson 9-5 overall a
3.06 era
the opposition's hitting 2-30 against
him
and the pitch
fly ball right center field herrera was
way over in back but he gets there but
he makes the catch
one out
back toward the middle spinning softly
segora's got it and martay
is retired two outs
ball right center field
the wind has got it so it's going to
stay
short of the track and o'dubo makes the
catch
now the diamondbacks are retired in
order
we head to the bottom of the first
set for the home half of the first
inning at citizens bank park your ram
truck starting pitcher for the
diamondbacks umberto mejia 24 year old
right hander
acquired from the marlins last season in
a trade for starling marte and an
encouraging d-backs debut in pittsburgh
on monday
that one's hit out toward right field
hit well over var show's head and it's
off to the top of the scoreboard oh
double on his way to second martial gets
the throw in but it's a lead-off double
20th double of the year for herrera
phillies are in business
segura hitting 315 with runners in
scoring position
the other way and that's ahead it's
going to scooped up by rojas he's got no
play segura will indeed get a hit over
to third is herrera
first and third with nobody out
you got bryce harper coming up 26 extra
base hits since the all-star break nine
homers here in the month of august
broke his back fly ball to right
marshall will get to it herrera tags
from third martial's throw goes to
second it's a sac fly one nothing fills
d.d gregorius coming up
drive the opposite way base hit
peralta's trying to cut it off sagore is
running to third he'll be held there
he's going to go through the stop sign
the throw home not in time the throw to
third is in time
it's an rbi double it's two nothing
bills
2-2 pitch
waiting to miss and he got him
the first strikeout
of the night or kyle gibson two outs
here in the third and now the 2-2 pitch
this one is
lifted out toward right center oh dubo
herrera got a good jump makes the catch
the inning is over
one hit allowed through three innings
for kyle gibson double herrera will be
the batter make it throw you something
good
that one's going deep to right field
that is good it is gone
just under the toyota side
oh doubles two for two
that's his 12th home run of the year
three nothing fills gene segura will be
the batter the o2 pitch
that one's hit well out to left field
peralta is going back toward the wall it
is gone
just over the flower bed back to back
home runs for the phillies
and they now leading four nothing here
in the third
off the end of the bat flare to center
field marte dives he can't get it it's
gonna go all the way to the wall varsity
nice job getting to it to back it up on
his way to third as miller the throw is
not in time
triple number three for brad miller
raphael marchand 22 year old switch
hitter
finds one to shortstop and now they
double off miller
and the he is out of the fourth
see if they go again they do
pitch rolled over to third
to reyes off balance throw in time to
get ahmed
it'll be second and third with two outs
he said he kind of ate him up a little
a bouncer softly to shortstop gregorius
has it mejia not really running that
hard
is uh an easy target
the diamondbacks
get a couple of base runners into
scoring position gibson has to throw 23
pitches in the inning but he gets out of
it with a four-nothing lead
and a strike three called on the inside
corner a sinker that came back
and paving smith strikes out for the
second time tonight
three strikeouts overall
now the diamondbacks go down one two
three
that is jose alvarado in his 47th game
4.32 era
i believe he went carson kelly went
around and he is striked out victim
number one for alvarado
[Applause]
swag and a miss
a cutter at 95.
he's basically throwing everything but
his 98-99 100 mile an hour fastball
fifth time that hector's made at least
50 appearances in a season
swinging a miss got him with the split
three strikeouts for the phil's
relievers
swinging to miss another strikeout
and another split little different one
than the one he threw a bar show yeah
that one looked like it had a little
slider on it
hector doesn't seem like he wants anyone
to put a ball in play three balls two
strikes
and a strike three called he got a
fastball right down the middle
so hector strikes out the side here in
the eighth inning
and harpers
spins it down the left field line it's a
fair ball and he's on his way to second
martial's throw is high
and bryce harper reaches 30 doubles
dd lines it to left field marshall on
the run he's not going to get there
you wanted some add-ons john
d.d gregorius
with an rbi double third double of the
night
[Applause]
and right through the vacant hole on the
left side an rbi for miller that'll
score dede gregorius
six nothing phillies
[Applause]
a bouncer out towards second should get
a run home and does
no double play on that one
swag and a miss
nice and easy at 99.
four straight strikeouts for the fills
relievers
the count one ball and two strikes to
bryant holliday
and the pitch
broken back one hopper over to third
terres has got it across the diamond in
time
and the ball game is over the phillies
have shot out the arizona diamondbacks
by a final score of 7 to nothing